[Musik]
gut gemeint ist dann doch oft schlecht
gemacht oder zur schell schlicht an der
Realität mit dieser Erkenntnis lassen
sich weite Teile der
Menschheitsgeschichte pflastern den
Bundeswirtschaftsminister scheint es
nicht anders zu ergehen jedenfalls mit
seinem ersten Anlauf zur Energiewende im
Gebäudebereich eine besonders
heimtückische co2-schleuder die die
Klimaziele massiv gefährdet also soll es
jetzt schnell und gründlich gehen nach
jahrelangen Versäumnissen diese massive
Beschleunigung bringt allerdings
Immobilienbesitzer und Mieter in
finanzielle Atemnot die als
Sauerstoffzufuhr gedachten
Fördermaßnahmen überzeugen bisher nicht
wirklich
habix heizungswände großer Wurf oder
Fiasko jetzt
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
Kerstin andre ist bei uns
Hauptgeschäftsführerin des
Bundesverbandes der
energie-grünen im Bundestag in Rigi
Rossbach ich stellvertretende Leiterin
der Parlament des parlamentsbüro der
Süddeutschen Zeitung hier in Berlin Kai
Warnecke ist Präsident von Haus und
Grund Deutschland ein Verband der
Privaten Immobilienbesitzer und
schließlich Albrecht von Lucke Publizist
und Redakteur der Blätter für deutsche
und internationale Politik und von Lukas
gleich als erstes dran eigentlich sollte
ja diese Woche das heizungsgesetz von
Robert habe im Bundestag debattiert
werden also sogenannten ersten Lesung
also eingebracht werden die FDP hat das
verhindert
wie viel hat denn das alles mit Harbeck
zu tun was da jetzt passiert gerade in
dieser Woche
die einzige Lage vor allen Dingen für
ihn im Moment denn habe steht ja ist ja
dreh- und Angelpunkt dieser Diskussion
sie ist sehr ernst für ihn aber sie ist
noch viel grundsätzlicher ernst was ich
an habe ich jetzt mal zugespitzt zu
sagen austobt regelrecht auch durchaus
man muss es klar sagen durch eine
Massierung von Fehlern was das
heizgesetz selber anbelangt dann die
Causa gleichen die das Zusammenspiel mit
den familiären Verhältnissen im Klima
und
Wirtschaftsministerium es spielt aber
zusammen mit der Tatsache und das macht
es so dramatisch dass wir mittlerweile
eine blockierte Koalition haben das eine
FDP regelrecht aus Prinzip dagegen hält
und nicht wie man von Anfang an es
eigentlich hätte sinnvollerweise machen
können konstruktiv als Korrektiv das war
einmal angesagt und das war von Anfang
an die Ansage von Handy aber
mittlerweile ist es eine klare
fundamentale Opposition so dass der
Hauptpunkt den habe ich jetzt stark
macht wir hätten es mit so etwas wie
Wortbruch zu tun weil die FDP regelrecht
dass die Debatte verhindert in der Sache
richtig ist die die Frage ist bloß ob
nicht tatsächlich das langsamere agieren
was ja dahinter steckt dem habe ich
schon Ansatz jetzt gerechter wird weil
der Widerspruch gegen das Gesetz so
massiv ist dass ein vernünftiges glaube
ich eher langsames agieren in der Sache
richtiger wäre aber die Blockade der
Koalition durch die FDP ist dramatisch
aber das macht langsam kurz beim
Bundeswirtschaftsminister er galt ja als
einst als beliebtester Politiker
Deutschland der Männer das Gefühl dass
er schon ewig lange her ist
wird er sich denn von diesem
Imageschaden noch mal erholen
das ist schwer zu sagen also ich meine
das haben wir schon viele Politiker
erlebt Aufstieg und Fall Jens Spahn war
auch mal der beliebteste Politiker
Deutschlands das hat sich dann auch
nicht materialisiert aber das kann auch
wieder in eine andere Richtung gehen er
ist eben ein sehr andersartiger
Politiker Typ als viele andere das
fanden glaube ich viele Bürger am Anfang
faszinierend und auch toll weil er eine
andere Art hat Politik zu erklären und
eben auch
deutlich macht wenn auch Außenpolitiker
zweifeln und und warum
tatsächlich stößt aber dass dann
durchaus auch an Grenzen wenn eben dann
auch inhaltliche Fehler passieren und
wenn erklären eben nicht mehr reicht
oder wenn auch so eine gewisse
Dünnhäutigkeit zu Tage tritt die dann
eben nicht passt zu dem abgeklärten
coolen lässigen Erklärer den er vorher
ergeben konnte wahrscheinlich auch
besonders groß gewesen da Warnecke das
heizungsgesetz ich habe schon am Anfang
gesagt schließt ja sowohl bei Vermietern
als auch bei Mietern auf breite
Ablehnung deswegen sind die
beliebtheitswertes
Bundeswirtschaftsminister gerade auch im
Keller was ist denn aus ihrer Sicht das
Hauptproblem des gesetzentwurst der da
jetzt diskutiert wird das Hauptproblem
ist das was sie eingangs schon erwähnt
haben das Gesetz zerschellt gerade an
der Realität und das ist das was den
meisten Menschen wirklich Sorgen gemacht
das Gesetz umzusetzen ist in der Praxis
für die meisten nicht bezahlbar das geht
mit dieser seltsamen havarieklausel los
mit der man einfach unterstellt wenn man
dann in den nächsten drei Jahren nicht
die passende Heizung findet es gibt ja
zum Beispiel kein Ersatz für
gassetagenheizung dann baut man sich
eben vorübergehend eine andere ein so
dass bei Kosten von von 15 20.000 Euro
das ist ganz gering für Heizung
fragt sich jeder normale Bürger wieso
soll ich eigentlich zweimal 15 oder 20
000 € in in 34 Jahren ausgeben und das
ist schon sehr Realität fern und wenn
dann die Technik auch noch fehlt es gibt
gar keine Geräte die man statt einer
Gasse Etagenheizung einbauen kann dann
kommt eben Frust und den Teilen auch bei
älteren Menschen zumindest Verzweiflung
auf die in ihren Häusern sitzen eine
kleine Rente beziehen der staatliche und
von denen ist es überhaupt nicht
finanzierbar und das hat glaube ich die
die Unzufriedenheit und die die die Wut
und verzweifl
hat sich Robert habe ich denn mit dieser
Gesetzesinitiative übernommen man muss
ja noch mal sagen ist
viele schl agworte von Heinz Hammer
heizungswände Hals und so weiter durch
die Gegend korrekt ist das ja eine
Novelle eines bereits bestehenden
Gesetzes des Gebäude Energiegesetzes
aber mit dieser Novelle also dem was er
was jetzt gerade auch in der
Öffentlichkeit diskutiert und hat er
sich da übernommen wurde er den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern auf einmal zu
viel zu
also es ist auf jeden Fall eine
Anforderung an die ja jeden einzelnen
betrifft und wir wissen ja aus vielen
politischen Gegebenheiten dass wenn man
in so seinem persönlichen Leben in
seinem persönlichen Alltag betroffen ist
dann gibt es eine ganz besonders hohe
Empfindsamkeit sage ich mal und trotzdem
ist es richtig dass wir ein Gesetz für
die wärmewende bekommen deswegen ist es
notwendig diese wärmewende entschlossen
anzupacken wir wissen dass 30 Prozent
unserer Energie im Gebäude Sektor für
Wärme ausgegeben wird und 20% der
CO2-Emissionen im gesamten Gebäudesektor
Entstehen dieses Gesetz muss dringend
verbessert werden es geht so nicht sind
ja viele Aspekte schon angesprochen
worden aber übernommen hat er sich jetzt
in dem Sinne nicht sondern diese
Regierung hat sich im Koalitionsvertrag
auf das Thema wärmewende verständigt und
das muss sie umsetzen und das jetzt
innerhalb der Koalition da ein Streit
ausgebrochen ist über diese
Fragestellung darf nicht dazu führen
dass das dringende Thema wärmewende
nicht angegangen wird wir uns jetzt
Inhalt und auch politische Implikationen
auseinanderhalten lassen Sie uns bevor
wir gehen auch noch auf die Substanz
dieses Gesetzes ein mal kurz einen Blick
noch hinter die Kulissen die Backstage
Ereignisse sozusagen dieses
wärmegesetzes dieses Gebäude
Energiegesetzes blicken
auffallend ist ja seit der Architekt
dieses Gesetzes
wirtschaftsstaatssekretär Patrick
reichen in der vergangenen Woche
entlassen wurde aus ganz anderen Gründen
ist ja dass die FDP so morgen Luft
Gewitter teils also jetzt plötzlich eine
grundlegende Überarbeitung gefordert ist
da der Hintergrund auch dass jetzt
sozusagen der hauptaktivist aus dem Weg
geräumt ist und wird vielleicht dieses
Gesetz auch noch da wird dem Gesetz ein
Urheber reichen noch zum Verhängnis
das glaube ich nicht also ich glaube
dass die FDP die hat ja schon bei ihrem
Parteitag sehr deutlich gemacht was sie
von dem damals vorliegenden Entwurf
gehalten hat nämlich nichts also da
wurde ja schon Mehrheiten auf dem
Parteitag organisiert für Anträge die
Ebene sehr starke Überarbeitung Neustart
eigentlich quasi neu Aufsetzen des
Gesetzentwurfs gefordert haben das heißt
die Position der FDP würde ich sagen war
bekannt die ist nicht neu
die hängt auch jetzt nicht an der Person
reichen natürlich ist es für das bmwk
also für das Wirtschafts- und
kinderministerium eine schwierige
Situation wenn der der Chef Architekt
sozusagen jetzt nicht mehr verfügbar ist
und sie diese wichtige Stelle erst neu
besetzen müssen mit jemandem der eben
natürlich auch nicht so drin ist in der
Materie aber der Entwurf ist jetzt
erstmal da und ich halte es auch für
total unwahrscheinlich dass dieser
Entwurf sozusagen wieder genommen und
entsorgt wird und der ganze Prozess noch
mal neu aufgesetzt wird mit einem neuen
Entwurf aus dem Wirtschaftsministerium
und ehrlich gesagt glaube ich auch dass
das auch von der FDP niemand davon
ausgeht sondern das schon davon
ausgegangen wird dass jetzt mit diesem
Entwurf sowie er da ist im Bundestag
gearbeitet wird dieses Straucheln von
von Robert habe dieses politische
Straucheln erschwert das tatsächlich die
die Gesetzesarbeit jetzt denn auf
irgendetwas muss man sich ja einigen die
meisten sind sich einig ein solches
Gesetz muss sein auch um die Klimaziele
zu erreichen jetzt gibt es massiven
Widerstand ja nicht nur in der Koalition
sondern auch in der Bevölkerung
erschwert dass die Arbeit jetzt für das
Gesetz dass der
Hauptprotagonist politisch gestorben ist
ungemein insofern man muss sich das
schon bewusst machen dieses ganze
zurückziehen das Gesetz ist das mag ja
Leute geben die ist für Patienten äh
quasi zurück auf Null wär natürlich auch
das wäre eine ein Schaden für ihn der
dramatisch wäre und ich glaube das
Grundproblem liegt noch an einer ganz
anderen Stelle an zwei Punkten dieses
Gesetz ist das erste Mal und das ist
glaube ich das Kardinalproblem dieser
Koalition gewesen in dem mal deutlich
gemacht wurde es wird uns der Schutz
künftiger Generation in der Gegenwart
etwas kosten im Koalitionsvertrag der
ganz stark die Handschrift in der
Hinsicht von sfdp aber auch der SPD
hatte als technokratisches
fortschrittsmodell war nie der Punkt
angesprochen dass wir gegenwärtig
gewisse Verluste hinnehmen müssen und
weil dieses Gesetz übrigens weil sie von
der Realität sprechen das Drama ist es
gibt ja gar keine klassische richtig
sehr viel ist ganz unbekannt bei dem
Gesetz das Drama hat dieses Gesetzes
besteht ja auch daran dass die Leute gar
nicht genau wissen was drin steht dieses
Gesetz dann auch mit dem Hintergrund
dass eben natürlich mit reichen und der
ganzen Familie beziehungsweise der
Tatsache dass etliche Angehörige
desselben grünen Think Tanks dahinter
standen erweckte den Eindruck hier wird
gewissermaßen technokratisch wieder am
grünen Tisch ein Modell umgesetzt was
natürlich dann besonders brutal wirkte
aber es ist erstmal ein ungeheuerlicher
Akt des Klima Ministeriums mit dem er
völlig allein gelassen wird auch vom
Kanzler übrigens nicht nur von der FDP
in dem klar gemacht wird es wird uns was
kosten es ist leider so brutal
und auch so maßlos in der in der in der
Projektionsfläche weil alle möglichen
Ängste auf dieses Gesetz projiziert
werden weil viele gar nicht wissen wie
es umgesetzt wird das ist das Kardinal
und die FDP und da muss es deutlich
sagen hat ganz unabhängig von diesem
Gesetz längst gesagt das war schon nach
der niedersachsenwahl wo regelrecht ein
Schalter umgelegt wurde wir werden mit
dieser grünen Partei kein Fehler machen
ich erinnere das Wort von Wolfgang
Kubicki die Zeit ist vorbei das muss man
sich schon auf der Zunge zergehen lassen
also eine richtige Kampfansage an die
Grünen und das ist unabhängig von dem
Gesetz es war bloß leider in der
Fehlerhaftigkeit und in der Causa auch
meine absolute steifvorlage und deswegen
ist das jetzt ein solches
Kardinalproblem was ist der sag mal der
FDP als Opposition in der Regierung so
ungemein leicht macht ungemein macht ich
will die Fehler ja nicht Leuten so
ungemein leicht macht Opposition zu sein
und das ist schon ein Punkt an dem habe
ich mit seiner Möglichkeit Spitze auf
Knopf steht auch sagen müssen das Gesetz
ist eigentlich komplett hinter
verschlossenen Türen im bmwk geschrieben
worden und reichen hat auf seinen
persönliches Netzwerk zurecht
zurückgegriffen was ja kann jeder machen
und dann kam die Ressortabstimmung und
all die ganzen Punkte in denen man
eigentlich diskutieren könnte zu einem
Zeitpunkt und in einer Geschwindigkeit
wo auch die Koalitionspartner eigentlich
kein Einfluss mehr hatten die SPD war
eingebunden über Frau greife Frau
Gallwitz wobei ich nicht den Eindruck
habe dass da viele Impulse aus dem
Bauministerium tatsächlich geflossen
sind und danach einfach ein Entwurf ein
Gesetzentwurf auf dem Tisch der einen
ganz ganz kleinen Satz aus dem
Koalitionsvertrag bzw dem
Koalitionsausschuss umsetzt mit einer
Wirkung für jeden einzelnen Bürger und
das ist doch ein riesengroßes Problem so
ein Gesetz kann man doch nicht hinter
verschlossenen Türen auf dem Weg bringen
das muss man immer gesellschaftlich
Aussehen man muss dazu sagen es bleibt
ja nicht hinter verschlossenen Türen was
ist da durchgestochen wurde
aus ihrer früheren beruflichen Tätigkeit
im Bundestag wissen Sie wie die
parlamentarischen Abläufe sind dass das
dann durchgestochen worden ist hat das
dem Gesetz wirklich massiv geschadet den
unter Robert habe kann die auch
außerordentlich dünnhäutig
reagiert als sei das ein richtiges
Sakrileg aber dadurch wurde ja auch klar
was geplant ist und damit ging natürlich
die öffentliche Diskussion auch los wir
reden alle von Transparenz und Offenheit
und da hat man ja offenbar im
Wirtschaftsministerium diese
Gesetzmäßigkeiten oder diese Wünsche die
die Grünen ja Jahrzehnte lang selbst
formuliert haben nicht beachtet das
Gesetz als es durchgestochen wurde war
ja noch nicht Ressort abgestimmt das
heißt es gab unterschiedliche Aspekte
die noch hätten diskutiert werden müssen
und es waren in diesem Gesetz Punkte
drin die hatten sie ja angesprochen was
die Förderung angeht was sind einzelnen
angeht die so nicht gut waren und ich
bin völlig bei ihnen er war nicht mein
hätte und man muss solche Gesetze viel
frühzeitiger mit den Betroffenen
diskutieren dann nimmt man sich ein
halbes Jahr Zeit dann geht man mit den
Verbänden ins Gebet lässt sich alle
Möglichkeiten auch dar Stellen am Ende
entscheidet der Gesetzgeber völlig klar
aber sich erstmal über die verschiedenen
Aspekte auch Informationen einzuholen
sind es die ist es die richtige
Schrittfolge was muss gemacht werden bei
so einem fundamentalen Eingriff 65
Prozent erneuerbare Energien in neuen
Heizungen das ist ein Hammer da muss er
erstmal die Energie dafür da sein da
muss die Infrastruktur dafür da sein da
muss das Haus im entscheidenden im
entsprechenden Zustand sein da muss
berücksichtigt werden ob die Menschen
sich das leisten können welche Sanierung
dahinter steht und das war der
eigentliche Fehler und das ein ein
Entwurf gelegt wurde der viele dieser
Aspekte entweder offen gelassen hat oder
eben auch Widersprüchlichkeiten hatte
war tatsächlich ein großes Problem aber
ich bin bei Ihnen die Koalition wäre ja
gut beraten wissen ja nicht wer wer
durch gestochen hat aber es wäre ja gut
gewesen wenn die Koalition sich
gemeinsam hinter dieses Ziel ein
vernünftiges Gebäude Energiegesetz auf
den Weg zu bringen verständigt und nicht
ein politisches Spiel um dieses Thema
macht nicht aus der Sache heraus sondern
aus der parteipolitischen Überlegung
heraus das heißt der League war ein
großes Problem hat zu viel
Verunsicherung beigetragen auch heute
reden wir noch über Teil also diskutiert
man teilweise noch Punkte die in neuen
Gesetz gar nicht mehr drin steht
trotzdem muss auch dieses neue Gesetz
verbessert werden fundamental verbessert
werden weil so ist es kein gutes Gesetz
das hat übrigens den Bundeskanzler dazu
gebracht Frau Roßbach das über Teile des
Gesetzes diskutiert werden die gar nicht
mehr drin stehen dass er meint dass sei
alles eine Aufregung das sei jetzt sei
eine unnötige Auflegung es sei jetzt ein
wörtlich ganz normales parlamentarisches
Verfahren
das ganze so in der die interpretiere
ich das jetzt ähm sei eine Art Sturm im
Wasserglas also wird von ihm richtig
runtergedient jetzt könnte man sagen
vielleicht will der Bundeskanzler auch
mal ruhiges Wochenende haben aber diese
Haltung von Scholz dieses über dieses
Gesetz in der Öffentlichkeit zu urteilen
und sein Verhalten in der Koalition bei
dieser Auseinandersetzung was sagt das
über den Bundeskanzler also das ist ja
sehr wenn ich besonders überraschend
weil es ist ja sozusagen also für Herrn
Scholze gibt es glaube ich nur sehr
wenige Dinge von denen er sagen wird die
sind jetzt aber wirklich aufregend und
dann Aufreger und die müssen wir jetzt
aufgeregt betrachten also ich glaube
dass der grundsätzlich
gerne Probleme ich will nicht sagen
klein redet aber zumindest versucht
emotional runter zu dimmen weil das auch
sein genereller Ansatz ist er ist eben
kein aufgeregter Typ und deshalb kann er
aufgeregung Aufregung erstens
wahrscheinlich nicht leiden und zweitens
auch nicht nicht immer verstehen und ich
meine dass man versucht aus seiner
Debatte die Schärfe rauszunehmen und zu
sagen jetzt nehmen wir uns einmal zurück
atmen durch und überlegen mal welcher
Schaden ist denn überhaupt angerichtet
und die lässt er sich heilen und
vielleicht ist alles gar nicht so
schlimm wie es irgendwie jetzt jetzt
wirkt und jetzt kriegen wir uns mal alle
gegenseitig nicht so auf und bringen uns
nicht auf die Palme das ist ja nicht
verkehrt also als Bundeskanzler muss er
natürlich auch versuchen zwischen den
streiten zu vermitteln aber irgendwann
kommt eben der Punkt wo er dann auch
sein muss und aufpassen muss dass ihm
das ganze jetzt nicht aus den Händen
geleitet und das dann eben in der
Situation Geräte die Koalition auf eine
Weise schädigt Vertrauensbasis etc also
dass sie dann gar nicht mehr
zusammenfinden Punkt haben wir ja längst
überschritten deswegen wird das nicht
aufgeregt sein eines Bundeskanzlers zu
einem kardinalen Problem wenn es eine
realitätsverdrängung und Leugnung ist
und wir haben den Punkt längst
überschritten diese Koalition ist ein
einer Situation wie ich mich nicht
erinnern kann das überhaupt in den
letzten Jahren eine Koalition gewesen
wäre und deswegen erinnere zurück also
es gab schon Koalitionen in denen man
sich gegenseitig also ja
die FDP war in der Situation eine Truppe
die quasi schon am Abgrund stand die hat
Frau Merkel quasi am langarm verhungern
lassen und auch was cdu/c so mein
Gedächtnis ist ganz gut das können sie
glauben CDU CSU sich geliefert haben mit
Herrn damals noch ein Seehofer an der
Spitze als Koalition Streit war auch
dramatisch aber wir haben es momentan
mit einer Koalition zu tun die in der
Sache und deswegen verstehe ich dann
stolz da nur bis oder ich sag mal anders
es geht da nicht ganz so weit weil ich
das die Lage also dramatisch wahrnehme
eine Koalition bei der von vornherein
Opposition der einen Partei als
Grundprinzip angesagt wird in der
größten Aufgabe diese Republik überhaupt
hat und die Feld nun mal Habeck und den
Grünen so das ist das gerade wenn wir
uns doch alleinig die große Frage und
wenn eine derartige Lage nicht
konstruktiv bewältigt wird und der
Kanzler keinerlei Anstalten macht seine
beiden Streithähne vorab in einem
Stadium an den Tisch zu bringen und zu
sagen wir müssen konstruktiv damit wird
diese Koalition uns doch das ist meine
Befürchtung zwei Jahre möglicherweise
Vergnügen bereiten aber zu keiner Lösung
kommen und deswegen ist diese Frage eine
andere als in früheren Situation es geht
auch heute um viel mehr es geht in der
Tat um vieles und deswegen nur als
kleine Sache der Kanzler ist durchaus in
der Lage sich über bekloppte und stolz
sie erinnern sich das heißt diese diese
völlig bekloppten die Aussage da kann er
sich erregen ob das nun sind wir nicht
klug war oder nur einem Wunsch nach
Stimmenfang geschuldet war ich hätte
schon eine ein ausgesprochenes Bedürfnis
in vielen der Punkten seitens des kannst
dass er die kardinale und die
entscheidende Figur ist ein ein Mehr an
Entscheidung übrigens auch ein mehr an
Willigkeit zu sehen dass er der Klima
Kanzler nur in ansetzen wird der uns
versprochen hat zu sein darf ich mal
ganz kurz ähm Warnecke es gibt ja sie
vertreten die Hausbesitzer hier die
erwarten ja jetzt etwas was kommt was
kostet mich das welche Übergangsfristen
gibt welche abfederungsmaßnahmen welche
Ausnahmen das sind ja für viele Menschen
ganz unmittelbare existenzielle Fragen
wenn man jetzt sieht dass ich da die
parteipolitikerinnen und Politiker
gerade in Berlin richtig an die Gurke
gehen auf offener Bühne was bedeutet das
was aus ihrer Sicht in wie weit ist das
schwierig für die für die Fortschreibung
des Gesetzes auch wie die Menschen auf
diese auf diese Auseinandersetzung
gucken die ja vor allem auch koalitions-
und machtpolitisch bedingt ist es ist
letztlich für die Energiewende ist es
fatal was jetzt gerade passiert wir
erleben ja auch dass gerade Heizungen
die 100% fossile Brennstoffe brauchen
jetzt ein Boom erfahren weil die Leute
sagen ich gehe lieber auf Nummer Sicher
kaufe mir jetzt noch mal ein Gerät eine
Gasheizung um die nächsten 20 Jahre
sicher zu sein aber da geht's ja schon
los das Gesetz wird es ja nicht
ermöglichen dass noch 20 Jahre lang
durch jedes Gasnetz in Deutschland auch
tatsächlich das fließt das heißt wer
jetzt eine fossile Heizung kauft hat
vielleicht das Problem dass er damit nur
noch 5 oder 10 Jahre heizen kann und
insofern bei allen Widerspruch den man
in so einer Koalition jetzt erlebt es
ist eigentlich der gesellschaftlich
Widerspruch den wir haben der sich in
der Koalition widerspiegelt und das
müsste eigentlich eine Chance sein für
FDP und Grüne zu sagen wir müssen das
jetzt in einer Art und Weise lösen dass
jeder Bürger jede Bürgerin mit dem
Gesetz umgehen kann ist es eigentlich
ziemlich banal
allein diese Idee 65 Prozent ist ja per
se schon absurd wenn ich noch 20 Jahre
habe dann kaufe ich mir noch in den
nächsten 20 Jahren nicht zwei Heizungen
sondern wenn ich jetzt auf erneuerbare
umsteige dann steige ich auf 100%
Erneuerbare um was soll ich jetzt mit
einer zwischen Heizung habe ich das Geld
gar nicht für so und wenn man diesen
Ansatzpunkt mal nimmt und nicht vom
Klima her oder von von Gaslieferungen
aus Russland her oder sonst woher denkt
sondern einfach nur vom Verbraucher dann
wird man relativ schnellen Weg finden
können und der setzt natürlich als
allererstes voraus dass die wärmeplanung
aber auch die Energieplanung auf den Weg
gebracht wird und zwar nicht so wie vor
geil wird das jetzt vorgeschlagen hat
mit gleich wieder dem dem perfekten
deutschen Modell wo man noch 20.000
zusätzliche Beamte brauchen sondern ganz
einfach so das ist für Bürgerinnen und
Bürger umsetzbar ist und da ist mit
dieser wärmeplanung die jetzt seit zwei
drei Tagen kursiert eine schöne nächste
Fehler auf dem Weg das wollte ich jetzt
gerade ansprechen ist hängt ja Winsen
Weisheit auch hier alles mit vor allem
zusammen man würde ja auch dieses
Dilemma deshalb Warnecke gerade
geschildert hat etwas mildern können für
die Menschen wenn es tatsächlich auch
Alternativen gebe man auswählen könnte
diese wärmeplanung ist da ein wichtiger
Aspekt dabei es geht aber um zeitliche
synchronisität auch darum dass das
aufeinander abgestimmt wird was ihr
offenbar noch nicht passiert ist man
könnte in den Kommunen ja durchaus auch
Fernwärme Abwärme Ähnliches anbieten die
Netze geben das im Moment noch nicht her
aber da könnte ja auch in den nächsten
Jahren etwas passieren liegt da der
eigentliche krucks dass diese
verschiedenen Aspekte ja als neue
Heizungen Gas raus Öl raus
Wärmepumpe rein vielleicht noch ein
bisschen Biomasse und im Altbau oder
noch ein Pelletofen und dass das aber
nicht so wurde für den Bürger auch klar
ist welche Möglichkeiten auch welche
Lösungen ist gibt die ähm die die
meisten dieser Probleme die da
aufscheinen vielleicht doch ertrinken
Entschuldigung erträglich machen
das Gesetz bietet ja viele Optionen
erstmal das wird uns mit dem Schlagwort
technologieoffenheit auch erklärt da ist
jede also sehr sehr viele Form der
Heizung drin bis auf Ölheizung und die
eigentliche Frage wie die Wärme ins Haus
kommt wie die Wohnung warm wird steht
und fällt mit der Frage welche
Infrastruktur und das ist das ist der
inhaltliche Fehler an dem Gesetz erst
muss geklärt werden welche Infrastruktur
liegt wo und dann kann entschieden
werden für welche Heiztechnologie
entscheidend zumindest wird der zweite
Schritt vom ersten gemacht nenn Ihnen
Beispiele sind ja das was sie jetzt
geschrieben haben die Unternehmen
könnten ja und die Kommunen könnten ja
das machen ja schon ganz viele sehr sehr
viele Unternehmen die wissen dass sie in
der Wärme liefern müssen dass wir
Umsteuern müssen überlegen zum Beispiel
in welchem Stadtteil lege ich in
Fernwärmenetz das dauert aber dass wir
teilweise schon gemacht das hat
angefangen wir haben eine Förderung für
diese Wärmenetze jetzt passiert ist
jetzt geht ihnen nach dem Gesetz haben
sie aber eine Gasheizung gemacht
steht kaputt und Sie müssen jetzt ein
neues kaufen was machen sie jetzt können
Sie sich für Sie wissen aber noch nicht
liegt da jetzt eine fernwärme ist es so
geplant kühn kommt da künftigen
Wärmenetze in das heißt es kann
passieren dass die Gemeinde der dieses
Stadtwerk über eine Förderung ein
Fernwärmenetz legt der Hauseigentümer
aber entscheidet über eine Förderung ich
mache eine Wärmepumpe und diese
Synchronisation erst die Infrastruktur
und dann die förderregime aufeinander
anpassen weil wir haben drei
förderregime wir haben das förderregime
rund um die Wärmenetze wir haben das
geweg jeden einzelnen und dann gibt's
noch das förderregime für die
energieeffizienten Gebäude weil die
müssen ja auch für sollten die Gebäude
Sanierung auch voranbringen das ja
sowieso und dieses aufeinander einpassen
also erst die Infrastruktur ein
integrierten Ansatz und dann die
förderregime aufeinander anpassen dann
wird die wärmewende auch Straßen gängig
dann funktioniert es auch aber der
Fehler ist nicht die Infrastruktur zu
betrachten und was sie mit den gasnetzen
sagen natürlich
müssen die Unternehmen dass es in
manchen Gebieten keinen Sinn mehr macht
ein Gasnetz aufrecht zu erhalten wir
haben aber ein Rechtsrahmen der einen
Anschluss eine Anschlusszwang
organisiert das heißt wenn sie sagen oh
ich mache hier ich lege hier noch mal in
Wärmenetz her hin aber da hinten sind
fünf die sagen ich hätte aber gerne
Gasanschluss dann müssen sie das
gewährleisten das heißt auch der rechts-
und Regulierungsrahmen rund um diese
Netze ist besonders und dann hat das
Gesetz ja noch so eine interessante
Variante das ist mit dem u80 Fall das
kann ja verstehen dass man sich
irgendwas überlegt hat was macht man mit
Menschen die sagen also ich bin da mal
ganz draußen was soll denn jetzt ein
Stadtwerk tun sollen die jetzt ungefähr
rauskriegen wie viele künftig in dieser
Region über 80 sind weil die dann
nämlich auf jeden Fall ein Gasnetz
brauchen werden weil sie vielleicht
nicht mehr aus ihrer Gasheizung
rausgehen also Infrastruktur zuerst also
bekommt das bekommen die Stadtwerke
Unterstützung vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht die das nämlich
schlichter greifen als verfassungswidrig
erklären lassen ich habe noch eine Frage
zu dieser
Konstellation im Heizungsbereich gut
drauf verwiesen ab einer Übergangszeit
gibt es müssen mindestens 65 Prozent der
der Energie im Gebäudebereich müssen mit
regenerativer Energie betrieben werden
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe
gibt es diese Geräte noch gar nicht
diese Technik gibt es noch gar nicht sie
ist auch noch gar nicht serienreif das
heißt man wird auf etwas verwiesen was
es gar nicht gibt und man weiß auch gar
nicht genau wann das tatsächlich dann
zum Verkauf steht ist das nicht verrückt
eine eine Technik anzupreisen die ist
noch gar nicht gibt also ich glaube es
gibt solche Kombi Geschichten schon also
so eine Mischung aus Wärmepumpe und
zusätzlich noch ein ähm
gasbrennen Kessel der sozusagen
anspringt wenn es so kalt ist dass diese
niedrige Vorlauftemperatur der
Wärmepumpe eben nicht reicht das gibt es
glaube ich schon aber es ist eben nicht
weit verbreitet und es ist mit
Sicherheit sie wissen dass mit
Sicherheit besser als ich aber es ist
auf jeden Fall teuer ja
also ich meine dieses Gesetz hat
natürlich der Grund ist das Gesetz so
ist wie es ist der liegt natürlich schon
auch da gibt's wieder diese Verbindung
mit dem mit der Person reichen
die kam eben in dieses Ministerium und
hatten einen großen Plan und der Plan
ist eben dass man die Klimawende
allelectric macht also dass man alles
elektrifiziert die Wärme den Verkehr
alles und wenn man davon überzeugt ist
das ist der richtige Weg ist und dass
die anderen da draußen das halt nur noch
nicht verstanden haben aber gleichzeitig
nicht für nötig befindet die Leute auf
diesem Weg mitzunehmen und ihnen das so
zu erklären und sich dann total wundert
dass alle sagen sorry wie kann das denn
gehen und was ist denn mit unseren
Netzen die wir schon haben und was ist
denn mit anderen Technologien und was
ist mit diesem und jedem dann braucht
man sich nicht zu wundern wenn es danach
ein riesen Aufschrei gibt und ähm dann
eben diese diese Form der Kritik kommt
also das ist das eine und das andere ist
es in diesem Gesetz ja eben auch
abgestellt wird zum Teil auf die
kommunale wärmeplanung die ist noch
nicht gibt also man möchte jetzt den
ersten Schritt für den zweiten machen
wie sie sagen schreibt den zweiten aber
schon mal ins Gesetz obwohl man den noch
gar nicht kennt und das alles liegt
natürlich darauf an dass man das
vorgezogen hat also letztes Jahr der
Koalitionsausschuss hatte gesagt CO2
Bepreisung wird verschoben wegen mehr
stark gestiegenen Energiepreise und zum
Ausgleich kommt dann dieses geplante
Gebäude Energiegesetz ein Jahr früher
und dadurch geriet man jetzt in
unheimliche Verdrückung ja man hatte ja
schon ein bisschen die Vermutung dass
seit dem Amtsantritt von Robert Habeck
im Bundeswirtschaftsministerium und
klimaschutzministerium hör mal
vielleicht eine
Mannschaft arbeitet die in einem
ökologischen Wolken kuckucksheim
unterwegs ist das was Frau Rosbach
gerade mit anderen Worten ausgedrückt
hat es gab ja schon bei der gasumlage
große Probleme mit der Kommunikation
durch den und von der ersten Fassung
oder dem ersten Versuch durch den
Bundeswirtschaftsminister
hat Robert habe denn diese Tatsache dass
da Menschen dann saßen Gesetze nur auf
die möglicherweise die Realität entweder
nicht wahrnehmen wollen oder nicht nicht
dafür interessiert haben auch
unterschätzt ist das ein permanentes
Kommunikationsproblem von ihm ja ich
würde sogar weitergehen die eigentliche
Tatsache dass dort man kann es ja
durchaus hart sagen in gewisser Weise
auch eine technokratische Ansatz
Hersteller die ganze von gleichen Jahr
maßgeblich
bearbeitete Strategie von agora
Energiewende ausgehend als dem Think
Tank dem er lange Vorstand war eben sehr
stark auf Wärmepumpe und diese Umsetzung
fokussiert das aber habe ich letztlich
die politische Dimension in sozialer
Hinsicht nicht als Politiker in dem Maße
im Blick hatte das scheint mir ein
riesen Problem zusammen ich glaube es
wird viel fundamentalere Frage auf wo
kommen auch Politiker und in dem Fall
ein Mann wie Robert Habeck an Grenzen
des Möglichen wenn man sich überlegt
schon im letzten Jahr da hat er ja
dürfen wir nie vergessen ungeheure
Erfolge deshalb auch gezeigt weil als
Wirtschaftsminister in Aktion hat er hat
das Land mit Energie versorgt
bis zum Kotau vor dem E-Mail von Katar
das habe ich gar nicht abfällig also den
Bücking wo man sagte da ist ein grüner
hochpragmatisch er sorgt vor allem
erstmal zur wirtschaftssicherheit
interessanterweise an der Spitze mit
Herrn reichen das war ja der Dank von
Robert habe ich gemacht sagte der hat
gleich ein großes geleistet da waren die
Sympathie Werte Erinnerung aber bis zur
Überarbeitung Stunde und in der ganzen
Klimawende also der Frage der Klima der
transformationsstrategie ist er in enorm
Schwierigkeiten geraten und da zeigt
sich für mein Verständnis wahrscheinlich
auch die fast Unlösbarkeit oder die
enorme Schwierigkeit ich müsste drüber
reden ich wüsste nicht ob es andere
Werke politischer ansehen gab die je so
von solcher Dimension waren das ist
enorm schwierig ist diese Frage der
politischen Vereinbarkeit mit einer
technischen Herangehensweise überhaupt
zu kombinieren und daran ist er glaube
ich maßgeblich gescheiter denn den
Vorwurf kann man reichen und Co gar
nicht nur machen das ist eine
ökologische technokratische
Herangehensweise aber nicht abgeschätzt
zu haben welche Folgen dieses Gesetz im
politischen Raum hat im
gesellschaftlichen Raum hat das glaube
ich fällt ein Stück weit schon auf
Robert habe zurück und also dass ich das
Anklagen formulieren würde weil es eine
riesige Aufgabe ist aber ich ich wüsste
auch übrigens nicht und das macht so
spannend wer sonst machen würde wenn
oder könnte denn die anderen die ihn
jetzt ja ungemein attackieren das ist ja
wirklich man muss immer deutlich sagen
jeden Tag treibt die Bild-Zeitung eine
eine neue Kampagne durch die Straßen
also mit neuesten umfragetest hier also
jetzt bringen 50% wollen habe ich weg
haben das ist schon in dem Wissen auch
darum dass wenn Haarwerk fällt man nicht
sofort sehen würde welche anderes
schaffen würde also das ist glaube ich
ein ganz grundsätzliches Problem wie
kriegt man ein solches mammutgesetz
überhaupt kommuniziert gemacht und
fertiggestellt das ist auch die sozialen
Schwierigkeiten mit dem Blick hat von
den politischen Folgen gesprochen die
vor allen Dingen auf habe zurückgewiss
es ist jetzt zweimal ein Name gefallen
in dem Lebens hat was auch symptomatisch
ist für diese Person die da offenbar
angeblich keine Rolle spielt nämlich die
Bundesbahn
die ja beteiligt ist mit ihrem
Ministerium als was die was die Gebäude
die energetische Gebäude Sanierung
angeht also entweder du sie sich immer
erfolgreich weg oder man nimmt sie auch
nicht wahr das ist ja sehr auffällig
dass wenn es gerade wenn es Problem hier
gibt immer habe ich eigentlich der
kugelfänger ist und sie dann immer nur
im Nebensatz erwähnt wird ist das
Absicht ist das unvermeidlich wie ist
die Rolle der bundesbauministerin da zu
sehen sie ist auf jeden Fall ein
gewisses Mysterium weil sie ja
eigentlich für einen Bereich zuständig
ist der die Leute in ihrem täglichen
Leben sehr betrifft die Wohnungsfrage
ist die große soziale Frage der
Gegenwart also
Immobilienpreise steigen Baukosten
steigen das wird viel zu wenig gebaut es
geht alles so langsam voran sie ist
natürlich an vielen vielen
Stellschrauben ist sie dran also von
irgendwie entschlacken der Bauverordnung
damit eben
typenweise genehmigt werden kann
aufstocken verdichten in
städtischen Gebieten und so weiter aber
es geht alles sehr langsam voran und sie
ist natürlich auch in dem Dilemma ja
also der Wohnungsbestand den kann man
nicht von heute auf morgen mit Schalter
umlegen klimaneutral machen man kann
auch nicht von heute auf morgen den
Neubau auf Knopfdruck ankurbeln wenn es
an Handwerkern fehlt an Materialien
fehlt die Preise sind und wenn
gleichzeitig natürlich auch noch die
Bauvorschriften auch energetischer Natur
immer teurer werden und irgendwie bewegt
sie sich da wirklich sehr seltsam immer
im Schatten ihre anderen
Kabinettskollegen obwohl sie so ein
wichtiges Ressort verantwortet es ist ja
tatsächlich so dass die hauptarchitekten
hinter dieser wärmewende glaube ich
schon im bmwk zu verorten sind weshalb
es schon auch richtig ist es habe ich
das Gesicht dieses Gesetzes und damit
auch das Gesicht der Krise um dieses
Gesetz ist aber trotzdem sollte man das
nicht vergessen dass auch im
bundesbaumministerium eine Verantwortung
liegt dafür dass wir in diesem ganzen
Wohnungsmiete und Energiebereich die
Füße auf dem Boden die im Dunkeln sieht
man nicht stimmt nicht von mir das
hatten sich da auch mehr Engagement aus
der Bund von der bundesbahnministerin ja
unbedingt ja wir haben das auch
gefordert wir sitzen im Bündnis davon
was war das Treffen geschildert und
diskutieren über lauter kleine
Stellschrauben und kann man hier noch
einen Cent einsparen oder gibt's hier
noch eine Möglichkeit bauen eine Idee
günstiger zu machen
180 Punkte liegen auf dem Tisch die
Bewegung ist fast gleich null das würde
ich Frau galwitz jetzt nicht unbedingt
vorwerfen weil es ständig ein Dreisprung
zwischen Bund Ländern und Kommunen ist
sind alle involviert beim Bauen da kann
man praktisch kaum Vorankommen aber das
Gebäude Energiegesetz macht diese ganzen
Bemühungen vollkommen zunichte weil das
was jetzt an Mehrkosten auch einen
wohnbestand
niederschlägt das können wir unsere
ganzen Bemühungen einstellen das ist ein
Vielfaches bei dem ganzen aber ich würde
gerne auch noch mal sagen dass sie das
ein bisschen anders sehe und das nicht
nur als ein politisches Problem sehr
dass er habe ich jetzt da vielleicht
nicht gespürt hat was die Gesellschaft
mitnimmt das ist doch sehr symptomatisch
wenn andere und ich hier sitzen und wir
eigentlich beide die selber Aussage ganz
praxisorientiert machen wie man vorgehen
müsste und vorangehen könnte und es ist
doch eigentlich immer so wenn man in der
Politik agiert dass wir sind in dem Fall
ja
Kunde und Versorger wenn sie jetzt so
ein Verhältnis haben zwischen
Arbeitnehmern und Arbeitgebern dann
jammern immer beide Seiten und sagt man
ist ein guter Kompromiss oder die einen
mehr und die anderen weniger also wenn
wir jetzt selber Horn blasen dann sind
wir doch offensichtlich als die ja zu
99,9% allein Betroffenen beide nicht
gehört worden und insofern glaube ich
ist es nicht ein Gespür Problem sondern
Herr harberg hat auch einen gleichen
Gesetz und Herren hat was ihm gar nicht
vorwerfen will aber wissenschaftlich
über Jahrzehnte einen einzigen Plan auf
dem Weg gebracht und dieser Plan ist
jetzt einfach stumpf umgesetzt worden
ohne ohne die Praxis einzubeziehen kann
man das nicht den Technokraten zum
Vorwurf machen und das ist meine Sachen
das Kardinalproblem von habe ich gesagt
leider ist leider das Problem
dann nicht gesehen dass er letztlich
selber die Kommunikation mit dem
Betroffenen betreiben muss die übrigens
hinausgehen denn ein sieht er
beispielsweise darin besteht dass
mittlerweile die Umsetzung der
Wärmepumpe dazu gehört dass der Staat 80
bis 90 Prozent möglicherweise der Kosten
für Wärmepumpen übernimmt lässt jeden
Mieter Fragen es ist ja erstaunlich was
der Staat in Eigentum alles finanziert
und wir als Mieter bleiben und
Betroffene das ist also auch es ist
eigentlich jeder betroffen und das ist
ja tatsächlich der vor dem ein Stück
weit habe ich machen muss er hat die
vielen Betroffenen über den
technokratischen Ansatz den gleichen und
Co an vertreten haben aus ihrer
Überlegung heraus den hat er nicht im
Blick gehabt und das ist leider wirklich
meine Sachen Problem
Mieterin und Mieter zahlen also nicht
steuern die Förderungen für die
Hausbesitzer sondern sie müssen ja
möglicherweise auch erhöhten die
Nebenkosten akzeptieren weil ein Teil
dieser Modernisierung umgelegt wird auf
die Nebenkosten wie ist das denn mit
diesem Vater geschrieben das wäre schon
mehrfach hier angesprochen worden ist
das sinnvoll so wie es jetzt angelegt
ist also ich finde das falsch und ähm
ich finde es also die Vorstellung dass
der Staat
Immobilienbesitzern wie die spds teil
diese will im Extremfall bis zu 80
Prozent der Wärme der neuen maximal
verstohlen ist Einkommen von 20.000 Euro
ab ist glaube ich der der Vorschlag von
den Grünen
ich weiß ja die Einkommensgrenze weiß
ich nicht auswendig aber jedenfalls
diese enorm hohe Fördersumme die führt
natürlich dazu dass Immobilienbesitzer
wie der Name schon sagt die besitzen ja
sozusagen schon was und die Immobilie
wird natürlich auch aufgewertet durch
eine neue Heizung und die Wertsteigerung
und so weiter ich weiß es gefällt ihnen
hören aber
so dass er wieder auf den Normalpreis
zurückwerfen
also wenn der Heizung irgendwann muss
sowieso ausgetauscht werden und
eigentlich ist er die Erzählung dass
diese Wärmepumpen sich in der bestimmten
Zeit amortisieren und dass man dann
sozusagen die Mehrkosten drin hat und es
dann sich lohnt weil verglichen mit den
steigenden Gaspreisen co2-preisen und so
weiter man dann einfach besser da ist
und dann frage ich mich eben wenn das so
ist wenn sich das lohnt dann finde ich
darf das eigentlich nur über Kredite die
dann eben staatlich gefördert nullzins
und so weiter darf das eigentlich nur
finanziert wenn du nicht über Zuschüsse
denn dann ist es ja sozusagen bekommt
man erst den Zuschuss hat dann die neue
Heizung die sich dann irgendwann noch
amortisiert dazu und die SPD
möchte ja vor allem ansetzen dass es
fördere sie im großzügiger wird und und
sozialer und so weiter aber irgendjemand
muss es bezahlen also dass das von der
Politik die Illusion aufrecht erhalten
wird das ist quasi nichts kostet dass es
möglich ist dass es niemanden mehr
kostet als als die bisherige Heizung die
er hat und die bisherige Art und Weise
also die Mieter nicht die Eigentümer
nicht niemanden und das ist einfach
nicht wahr weil das Geld muss irgendwo
herkommen und wenn es aus dem Schulden
kommen
möglicherweise gar keine Kredite mehr
kriegen aber diese Förderungen also was
ist aus dem Vorschlag bei dem Bündnis
grün glaube ich kam aus der Fraktion bis
20.000 Euro zu verstehen ist Einkommen
80%, dann 50 dann 40 dann 30 glaube ich
alles über 80.000 € zu versteuern des
Jahreseinkommen ist dann müssen die 30
Prozent zufrieden sein kann man sich
natürlich auch fragen wie viele Menschen
gibt es mit hausbesitzt die weniger als
2000 oder 1.500 Euro im Monat zur
Verfügung haben der gut also die für 30
Jahren gebaut haben und jetzt aber
möglicherweise aus anderen Gründen das
Haus verkaufen müssen was gar nicht zu
dem Heizungstausch zu tun hat
symptomatisch die Tatsache dass es also
man müsste natürlich von staatlich
geförderten Krediten sprechen zu WE
sentlich erwarte Bank geben würde mit
weniger Sicherheit und so weiter aber
die Tatsache dass sie sagen es gibt auch
Rentner die kriegen womöglich gar keinen
Kredit mehr die zeigt einfach dass der
Ansatz für alle Immobilienarten für alle
Lebenssituationen und für alle
Gegebenheiten ein Modell im Prinzip zu
fordern dass der nicht funktioniert hat
so unglaublichen Ineffizienzen wenn man
das machen würde über wenn man natürlich
haben wir zu spät angefangen ja also
wenn wir jetzt vor 15 Jahren angefangen
hätten mit der wärmewende dann wäre die
Möglichkeit gewesen dass jeder zu dem
Zeitpunkt zu dem es sich für ihn lohnt
in der Lebenssituation mit Blick auf die
Immobilie die er besitzt dann den
Schritt macht wenn es passt und das will
man darauf will man oder kann man jetzt
nicht mehr warten und deshalb möchte man
ein totalmarkt fernen Ansatz der dann
eben solche Fragen aufwirft natürlich
wäre 75 60 65 ist für den lohnt sich das
womöglich nicht diese Investition aber
dann ist die Frage muss man sie dann
trotzdem erzwingen zu diesem Preis
gesellschaftliche und monetäre Kosten
80 Regelung tatsächlich auch Bestand hat
Frau andre
kosmetische Änderungen reichen in keinem
Fall aussagt der FDP-Generalsekretär
John Saray
ja muss es ein ganz neues Gesetz her
oder kann man auf der Basis dieses
Gesetzes Vorhabens dieses Entwurfs der
jetzt schon ganz kurz vor den Türen des
Bundestages steht und anklopft kann man
daraus noch das ändern und besser machen
was bisher allgemein kritisiert wird ja
das geht man kann dieses Gesetz als
Gerüst nehmen und dann verknüpft man es
mit der Infrastrukturplanung das ist vor
allem die kommunale wärmeplanung was ja
jetzt gerade in der Ressortabstimmung
ist diskutiert wird das muss unabdingbar
davor liegen dann braucht man einen
rechts- und Regulierungsrahmen für die
Gasnetze die abgeschrieben werden sollen
sie müssen sich vorstellen sondern
Unternehmen hatten es ist ein Büchern
eigentlich 45 Jahre jetzt sollen die
sofort abgeschrieben werden dann muss
sie irgendeinen Formen von
Sonderabschreibung organisieren damit
Liquidität da ist irgendwas anderes zu
machen und ich muss ja denen auch eine
Perspektive geben und dann passe ich das
ein über die förderregime die es schon
gibt und schaue mir eine soziale
Förderung an die da passt genau ist dann
verlängere ich die Übergangsfristen drei
Jahre ist zu kurz fünf Jahre würde da
mehr Sinn machen und zwar ab Vorliegen
einer Infrastrukturplanung und dann wird
es schon gängig das Gesetz aber wichtig
ist wenn wir jetzt nur verschieben und
nicht verbessern dann tun wir der
wärmewende überhaupt kein Gefallen wir
müssen dieses Thema angehen dass sie
haben ja gesagt wir haben da schon Jahre
nichts getan es wird immer kürzer und
immer dringender das was getan wird aber
es muss eben passgenau sein es muss
volkswirtschaftlich effizient sein und
es muss die Menschen in verschiedenen
angeht ja von Glucke die FDP hat jetzt
vorgeschlagen das reicht auch im Oktober
das alles noch zu verabschieden im
Oktober sind rein zufällig
Landtagswahlen in Bayern und Hessen
möglicherweise mit ziemlich maulen
Ergebnisse für die ampelparteien sowie
die Umfragen jetzt gerade Aussehen
möglicherweise gibt es ja danach dann
dieses Gesetz gar nicht mehr in dieser
Form ist politisch gar nicht mehr
durchsetzbar
naja das ist die Frage die große Frage
könnte man genau andersrum drehen das
Gesetz wenn es den Test tatsächlich nach
dem habe ich schon Modus noch vor dem
Sommer durchgesetzt wurde ohne dann all
die grundsätzlichen Veränderungen die
wahrscheinlich wirklich in erheblichen
Umfang erforderlich sind wäre in meinen
Augen eine ziemliche Steilvorlage genau
für den Wahlkampf also ich habe deswegen
große Zweifel ob habe ich nicht da so
einen Gefallen getan hat jetzt aus
Gründen auch ein Stück weit bei der
verteilt ist weil es ein ungehörigen
Konflikt gibt auch um nicht das Gesicht
zu verlieren darauf zu setzen wir müssen
es schleunigst und noch vor dem Sommer
durchbringen ist meine Sache dann auch
gerade was die FDP anbelangt fast eine
stallvorlage die FDP kann dann sagen
okay du hast es so gewollt das Gesetz
haben wir in der Art nie gewollt dann
können wir umso mehr Opposition aus der
Regierung machen und er sich auch immer
freut das ist ja das eigentlich in Farbe
wenn es nicht in Farben denn es ist auch
normales politisches Geschäft aber
natürlich steht eine CDU CSU Opposition
wie heute immer Fax Unternehmen und sagt
mach doch mal zeigt uns was ihr zu
bieten habt also es ist momentan nichts
leichter als das zu sagen
wer das macht macht die großen Fehler in
einer solchen gewaltigen Aufgabe ist es
so leicht sich zur Seite stellen und das
ist fatalerweise momentan die Rolle der
FDP deswegen weiß ich nicht ob habe ich
so klug beraten ist wenn er sagt wir
machen es jetzt sehr schnell ich hielte
ist für sinnvoller zu sagen die Zeit
sollte man sich eher nehmen und dann
etwas Vernünftiges machen aber das
Problem war ja dass es wurde ja darauf
gedrungen das Gesetz durchs Kabinett zu
bringen obwohl bekannt war dass die FDP
Ministerien und die FDP-Fraktion ist so
nicht mittragen und trotzdem hat Harbeck
und Scholz darauf gesetzt dass es durchs
Kabinett geht weshalb es an diesen
Kabinettsbeschluss gab mit der Fußnote
von Christian Lindner ich gebe hier mit
zu Protokoll dass wir nicht
einverstanden sind und jetzt hat man den
Salat also hätte man das nicht gemacht
sondern hätte die Ressort Abstimmung
noch ein paar Wochen länger gemacht es
ist kein Wert an sich das vor dem Sommer
zu verabschieden und ganz ehrlich Markus
Söder wird auch ein nicht
verabschiedetes Gesetz und ein
verabschiedetes genauso in den Zentrum
seines Wahlkampf Rücken ich glaube da
braucht 120 Sekunden gehört haben ist
eine gute Nachricht für die Phönix Runde
da auch in der nächsten Zeit viel zu
diskutieren zu diesem Thema ich bedanke
mich bei Kerstin Andrej bei henriege
Roßbach bei kaiwaneke und bei Albrecht
von Lucke Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe
Zuschauer morgen in der Phönix Runde
Kampfjets für die Ukraine droht eine
Eskalation
aktuelles in Phoenix der Tag mit Maja
Weber das Thema unter anderem die
Statements zur bundesweiten Razzia gegen
die Aktivisten der letzten Generation
bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]